hello everyone my name is reto meier and
welcome to this week in Android
development this week in Android
developers live Roman Nick and Adam will
be hosting the first episode of Android
design in action live out of our New
York and London studios this week's
theme is transit apps so they'll be
taking some of the apps that Ian and I
looked at on the App clinic last Friday
and give it in a design makeover on
Wednesday we have three Android
developer office hours scheduled
starting with a European friendly
broadcast coming out of our London
studio at two p.m. british summer time
few hours later at two p.m. pacific time
join hosts Joe melon and Trevor Jones as
they answer your Android developer
questions live this week's topic is
building Android apps using the web so
make sure you put your questions in the
moderator or join us live via hangout to
participate during the broadcast then on
Thursday Bruno will be broadcasting live
from Sao Paulo for a Portuguese language
edition of Android developer office
hours that's at 7pm sup all the time in
the Lewis and I were putting stopwatch
and timer apps on the table during the
app clinic on friday at 1pm pacific time
our goal is to help developers learn the
tips and tricks that it takes to make a
good app and make it great so be sure to
use the moderator page link here to
nominate the stopwatch and timer apps
you would like us to take a look at
straight after the app clinic joined and
album in this week's celebrity headwear
for another episode of the Friday games
review that's a 2 p.m. pacific time
dance decided to go freestyle this week
so there's no set thing just use the
moderator page and let us know which
games you'd like down and he's had to
review this week as always you can keep
track of what we've got coming up on
android developers live at
developers.google.com/live / android and
as got a complete schedule of all of our
upcoming broadcasts as well as links to
all of our previous shows speaking of
which in addition to our regular office
hours last week inna and I looked at
transit apps particularly off e.m
parking quick Muni london underground
STM and the UK bus checker and on the
Friday games review dan & Co reviewed
collectible card games both of these
videos are now available for you to
review on YouTube
in other Android developer news last
week we learned that we now have over
480 million Android devices activated
with another 1.3 million devices being
activated every day as always there were
many apps launched last week and some
upgrades including an update from Q&A
app Korra the official US Open app
quotes a new out for tracking your
investments and a new update from
note-taking app catch that's all from
this week in Android development my name
is reto Meier thank you for watching